i started my architecture degree
alongside 500 other students fast
forward 5 years and only 50 of those
students successfully graduated only 10
of those 50 students are now practicing
qualified architects with a thriving
career that means you only have a one
percent chance of a successful
architectural career in today's video
i'm breaking down exactly what
architectural software you need to know
in order to be in that top 1
if you stick around to the end of the
video i'll share with you exactly what
you need to do to work smarter and not
harder but yet still be in that top 10
now let's break down these architectural
softwares into three different
categories design render and present
each one of these categories is critical
and you are going to need to learn all
of these softwares at some point in time
so first of all we're going to talk
about the design category personally i
believe there is only two architectural
softwares you need to learn and master
during your university or college degree
in order to be successful the first is
archicad and the second is revit now i
know i'm going to upset a lot of people
in the comments down below by only
recommending these two softwares but
there is valid justification archicad
and revit are extremely well known and
extremely well used in the industry
around the entire world that means your
likelihood of success and your
likelihood of landing a job with a firm
that uses one of these two softwares is
absurdly large even though there are
great architectural softwares out there
that many of you suggested in my last
video some of those unfortunately are
not commonly known
so even if you want to go out and learn
vector works or chief architect or
anything like that yes by all means go
ahead but keep in the back of your mind
that a job is the end goal and without
this you're most likely not going to
have a successful thriving career that's
why i always recommend students learn
archicad and revit i'm not saying learn
one or the other i'm saying learn both
this is where the most critical piece of
information in this video is if you do
not learn both then you're setting
yourself up for a 50 50 chance of
landing a firm that uses that software
the worst thing you want to do is apply
for your dream job and then them tell
you oh sorry we only use archicad and
you've learned revit in my experience
knowing both softwares and having both
of them on your resume is critical to
successfully moving forward next we move
on to the rendering category and again
there is only two pieces of software
that you need to learn in this category
you can learn either or you do not need
to learn both now i recommend twin
motion and enscape there is again a very
valid justifiable reason why i recommend
these two pieces of software rather than
going ahead and learning some really
high-end rendering softwares so both
twin motion and enscape will give you
relatively good imagery in a relatively
short period of time subject to the
quality of your computer you might even
be able to get some exceptional renders
out of these simple software packages
nonetheless you're not looking to be an
architectural visualization expert
you're looking to be an architect who's
going to architect your school so
therefore my best recommendation is to
stick to these lower end architectural
rendering softwares otherwise there is a
very high likelihood you could end up
with some amazing 3d renders absolutely
but then get pushed into a corner at
your new firm where the only thing that
you focus on is three-day renders so for
the next five ten years of your career
before you're able to advance anywhere
or talk to anybody all you're going to
be doing is pretty pictures and that's
not what any architect who's going to
architecture school
wants to do last but not least it is
critically important that you understand
how to present your work and also how to
present yourself as an architect one of
the best things you can do is actually
present yourself and market yourself
that's why i recommend all three of
these softwares be learned very very
early on in your university stage first
of all you're going to need to know
photoshop you're not going to need to
know all the intricate details of
photoshop but you're going to need to
know the bare bones essentials photoshop
is an overwhelming program if you've
never used it before but it is a very
simple program to do all things
architectural related i do highly
recommend all students elect some sort
of graphic design course that way they
can learn photoshop and everything under
that umbrella relatively quickly and not
have to understand everything that
photoshop can actually do alongside
photoshop you also want to learn
illustrator illustrator is where you're
going to be able to produce some
incredible diagrams
and as we all know architects love
diagrams nowadays not many people will
put pen to paper but many people will
put mouse to computer so our
architectural diagramming skills need to
be on point and this is how we convey
some of our most simple ideas in the
quickest way possible illustrator is
another one of those adobe programs that
is so complex but you only need to know
the bare bones essentials of diagramming
and what vector graphics are rather than
just pixel graphics and why they are so
important to everybody as a practicing
architect last but not least is indesign
this is basically the one stop shop that
you're going to be able to compile
everything into and create some of the
best presentations you've ever done your
life now there are a million one
versions of photoshop illustrator and
indesign available on the market i'm
just using these three as the
fundamental principles so photoshop
allows you to edit manipulate photos
illustrator allows you to create amazing
diagrams and indesign allows you to
package it all up and present the best
thing possible the best part about
learning these name brand softwares is
that every architectural firm is most
likely already using it therefore when
you place on your resume i know
photoshop illustrator and indesign this
is a huge green tick for anybody
reviewing your resumes not to mention
that presenting amazing quality work is
going to land you a significantly higher
grade at university or college compared
to somebody with a great design but
exceptionally poor presentation skills
the worst part about this list is that
yes you need to master all of these
softwares if you want to increase your
chances of being in that top one percent
however if you know what kind of
architect you want to be and if you know
what architectural firms you potentially
want to work for
then there is a chance you can only
master some if i figured this out early
on in my university career god knows
where my career would be today however i
did manage to figure it out at the end
and it was one of the best things that
projected my career into the place it is
today what i recommend to everybody
right now is make a list of your top
three architectural firms that you want
to work for and not just firms that you
want to apply to after you've narrowed
down your top three firms make sure you
email and call every single one of them
and if you can also try to arrange an
in-person meeting ask for just three
minutes of their time don't ask for five
ten fifteen ask for three you wanna ask
for an extremely short period of time
that most logical people cannot say no
to you want to make sure you come into
it very quickly with rapid fire
questions to get in and out of three
minutes so that you respect their time
and they respect you but in the same
time you want to develop these
relationships so by simply forming
connections with architectural firms you
want to work for you not only figure out
what architectural software they use how
they render how they present and how you
can master those exact softwares
you also build relationships with the
person that will most likely be hiring
you when you finish your degree anyway
that's all from me today guys thank you
so much for watching my name is david
zomich and if you enjoyed this video
make sure you check out the playlist to
the side of me for great architectural
content if you loved this video i'd
appreciate it if you smash that
subscribe button and if you have any
questions leave them in the comments
down below but like always i will see
you next monday